[Music]
Disney is wildly popular so it makes
sense that other people would want to
get a piece of the pie and coffee Disney
stay tuned to find out which knockoff is
causing a big lawsuit are you new around
here don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up and subscribe to the
things for more great content like this
now on to 10 Disney princes knockoffs
from around the world Beauty and the
Beast some of Disney's most popular
movies are the ones that involve Disney
Princesses just think about it those
movies are the epitome of fairy tales so
it only makes sense that other companies
that want to copy something that is so
successful which brings us to golden
films Beauty and the Beast which is
basically an exact replica of the Disney
classic except that in this new film
Belle is a blonde but even with the
slight change it doesn't seem like this
movie should have been allowed to be
made it even has the same name as the
original the storyline is a bit
different though in this film Belle has
siblings she spends a lot of time with
them and also helping the less fortunate
one day her father's cargo ships are
lost in the China Sea so the family
loses most of their wealth they then
have to move into a small cottage and
have to work in the fields one day they
get word that one of the ships has
survived so the father goes to the
harbor to retrieve it on his way back he
gets too lost in the forest and decides
to spend the night in a castle on the
way while there he sees it rose and cuts
it for his daughter and is in prison
from there the stories are pretty much
the same that little mermaid do
copyrights mean nothing anymore
they must not because golden films also
made their own version of The Little
Mermaid the premise of the two films is
the same but golden films princess is a
little different from the one we know
and love in the knockoff film Ariel's
name is Lena she is still young and
adventurous
she is pretty happy living her life
under the sea and how she meets Prince
Stefan who is a human and falls in love
this is where the story starts to get
crazy similar to the one we all know
Lena realizes that she will never be
able to be with Stefan unless she
becomes human though she visits the
witch Cassandra cough-cough Ursula
Ursula sorry Cassandra then turns Leena
human in exchange for her voice
first she warns her that if Stefan
marries someone else she will be turned
into seafoam harsh right
luckily for Lina it all works out in the
end but no one is really surprised it's
a fairy tale after all you can't have
the main character risking it all for
love and then spending eternity as foam
that would not be inspiring at all at
least both versions of the movies have
happy endings
Pinocchio okay Pinocchio may not be a
Disney Princess but his film was ripped
off too
so we had to mention it we all know the
story of Pinocchio the little boy who
couldn't stop lying seriously what was
that kid's problem you would think that
if your nose grew every time you told a
lie you would learn to tell the truth
really quickly right anyway in 1992
good times entertainment decided to make
their own version of the classic story
with the same name in the second version
a spark of magic escaped from the blue
fairy's home and made its way down to
Geppetto's chimney Geppetto as we all
know was a toymaker
so when the magic spark made its way
into his shop it brought one log to life
fast forward and Gepetto's toys aren't
really being sold anymore so he decides
to make one toy just for himself he
unknowingly uses the magic log to do so
the toy that he made soon comes to life
and becomes Pinocchio through lots of
trials and tests Pinocchio eventually
learns what it takes to become a real
human and gets his wish of becoming a
real boy sound like something you've
heard before Cinderella Cinderella is a
classic to end all classics you'd be
hard-pressed to find someone who hasn't
seen the disney version of the film
while you may think that you know
everything about Cinderella did you know
that there was another version of the
movie yep
in 1994 jet lag Productions decided to
make their own version of the film in
this film we actually see Cinderella's
mother for a bit but she soon becomes
ill and passes away leaving Cinderella
motherless and her father wifeless of
course Cinderella's dad doesn't stay
single for long he eventually goes on to
marry a woman with two daughters
unfortunately for Cinderella the woman
is pretty much the spawn of Satan and
her two daughters are just as evil when
the father goes away on a business trip
Cinderella's stepmother and sis
take away all of her things and force
her to act as a servant in her own house
she's even made to sleep on a straw mat
in front of the fireplace but her luck
changes when she makes her way to a ball
that the king is having for all single
women in the kingdom and you know the
rest
sooner belly goes to the ball difference
falls in love with her and lo rest until
he finds her again La Bella the men say
not to be left out of the copy-cat world
Sleeping Beauty has also been made over
La Bella Demi ante is the Spanish
version of the film
the title pretty much translates to the
pretty girl sleeps
which is exactly what Sleeping Beauty
did throughout the whole film there is
also a Japanese American version of the
film that good times entertainment
released in 2002 as part of the
collectible classics line of films in
this film the princess's name was
princess Felicity and not Aurora but the
basis of the movie is the same the film
starts out in a kingdom where the king
and queen have been wanting a daughter
for a long time once they finally have
one they have a huge celebration each of
the fairies in the kingdom was invited
and asked to be the godmother of the
girl all except the evil fairy Oh Delia
because of this Oh Delia gave the baby a
curse
saying that when Felicity is 16 years
old she will prick her finger on the
spindle of a spinning mill and pass away
the other berries were able to change
the curse so that Felicity would not
pass away once she's pricked instead she
would fall into a deep sleep that would
last for 100 years unless she is kissed
by her true love you know how the story
ends snow white snow white is a classic
in fact the movie Snow White and the
Seven Dwarfs is one of the oldest Disney
movies around everyone loves the story
of the beautiful maiden he was able to
escape the clutches of her horrible
stepmother and befriend a motley crew of
Seven Dwarfs just talk to him about it
is making us want to go back and watch
the film
the popularity of the movie didn't just
catch our eyes though it also caught the
eyes of director Tasha you people Eva
and because of that a Japanese American
version of Snow White was created in
Disney's film Snow White has short black
hair and it's quite hell in this version
of the film Snow White has long flowing
black hair and looks to be a bit Tanner
than her Disney counterpart in this
she has sent away to live in the woods
because of the jealousy of her
stepmother whereas in the other film she
ran off to the woods to escape her
stepmother
from there the storylines are pretty
similar snow-white beats for Seven
Dwarfs and then eventually her true love
don't you just love when everything
turned out right young Pocahontas
everyone knows the story of Pocahontas
she was the daughter of a native chief
she loved nature and loved her tribe but
she also loved exploring even more when
she fell in love with John Smith her
world turned upside down he was there to
colonize her lands but instead she fell
in love with him later when he was
captured she risked her life to save him
but what we don't know about Pocahontas
is what happened before that what
happened before her dad wanted her to
marry kocoum what happened before she
met John Smith and changed her life
forever we don't know which may be why
illumination Filmworks decided to make a
movie called young Pocahontas the movie
showcases Pocahontas is life before the
Disney story but was that really their
story to tell if Disney came up with the
story of Pocahontas then shouldn't they
own the rights to the whole story how
can another company just come in and
make a version of the movie that is
supposed to occur before the one that
Disney made it really makes no sense we
need some answers
speak for yourself illumination
Filmworks we need answers and we need
them soon Esmeralda so technically as
Marella is into Disney Princess in real
life but in our hearts she's just as
much of a princess as Belle or our girl
Cindy the movie The Hunchback of Notre
Dom follows her in her friendship with
Quasimodo who lives in the clock tower
through the course of the movie the two
develop a friendship that not only
defied odds but was ridiculously
heartwarming as well the movie was so
great so of course there have been
copies take the secret of the Hunchback
for instance which was created by UAV
corporation in 1996 this movie was
basically just a lower budget remake of
the Disney classic but univie
corporation wasn't the only company that
wanted to get their hands on this
classic tale jet lag product
and good times entertainment also
collaborated to make their own version
of The Hunchback of Notre Dom in 1996
even with all of these fakes no one
loved any other version of the movie
more than Disney's how could you
Disney's version was the first and best
and it had the only version of the
characters that made any sense when it
comes to bootleg and Disney movies other
companies should just take a seat
because no one is ever going to choose a
Disney knockoff over the real thing
tangled up in the previous entries it
seems like Disney just lets people copy
them doesn't it all these knockoff
princesses and knockoff movies don't
seem to really have any repercussions
but when it comes to tangled up which is
a UK version of the popular movie
tangled Disney is not taking it lying
down
Disney is suing the company bright spark
productions that made the film
apparently this isn't the first time
that bright spark has done something
like this the company has been around
since 2006 and has been selling Disney
knockoffs for around $12 a piece both
online and around the world when they
released raver which was a spinoff of
Disney's brave Disney finally decided
they had had it in a statement Disney
said that people place a lot of trust
and Disney and the quality of their
films they said that the other company
was causing confusion among Disney
consumers and that they felt as if they
needed to protect their loyal consumers
the statement went on to say that goofy
believes at bright spark has a pattern
of misguiding their customers and is
making a card for Disney customers to
trust what they are buying so much drama
we can't wait to see how this all turns
out
we really don't know why these companies
are trying so hard to copy Disney if you
are going to copy someone you should at
least try to be a little more creative
about it but these companies apparently
don't care who knows that they are
copycats the Indian company shimmery
entertainment apparently liked Disney's
Braves so much that they decided to come
out with their own version it was
originally called Super K the movie but
when it was localized for
english-speaking areas the movie was
called Kiara the brave what's crazy
about the film is that Kiara bears a
striking resemblance to Merida
don't you think there are a few slight
differences in the film's though PR is
film is set in an imaginary Kingdom
called dream zone while brave takes
place in Scotland in brave Merida is
trying to break a curse while Kiara is
focused on saving her father from this
kidnapper when Kiara the brave first
came out Pixar failed to comment on the
copycat film but what we are wondering
is why not if a film so obviously copies
you why wouldn't you say anything about
it we would shout it from the rooftops
if someone was copying us the fakes must
be exposed that's it for 10 Disney
princes knockoffs from around the world
what did you think about the knockoffs
they annoy you let us know in the
comments thanks for watching
[Music]